جمعهما الفن وعشق التراث السوداني في قصه
حب توجت بالزواج فمن
رحم الاحزان تولد الافراح دوما تفاعل كبير
مشاهدينا شاهده الشعب السوداني عبر مواقع
التواصل مع خبر زواج الفنانه الشابه انصاف
فتحي والباحث في التراث مهند الزواج اثار
ضجه واسعه وتفاعلا ايجابيا في الوقت الذي
يعيش فيه السودانيين احباطا كبيرا بسبب
ظروف الحرب الحاليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من القاهره العروس انصاف فتحي اهلا بك
معنا والف الف مبروك هذا الزواج فعلا وهذا
الفرح الذي يخرج من رحم الاحزان والمعاناه
الان في السودان
مرحب بك
اهلا وسهلا لا بدناش يكون هيك كلامك بكل
المتابعين العربيه تفضلي طيب
شويه بصوت طيب يعني
قصه جميله جدا خصوصا في ظل الظروف الراهنه
الان في السودان خبرينا كيف هيك بلش يعني
كيف بلشت ابتدا هو
ايضا خبير تراث وانت فنانه يعني مجالين
متباعدين بشكل كبير كيف التقيته
طيب في البدايه التحيه للشعب السوداني
الصابر الشعب السوداني المظلوم اللي بيمر
بالظروف صعبه اللي هي ظروف الحرب في
الفتره الحاليه بتمنى تزول المحنه
ويرجع السداد زي ما كانوا احسن ان شاء
الله
بتمنى الاستقرار والامن للمواطن السوداني
للشعب السوداني
العلاقه اللي بيني وبين
مهندس ما عارفه انه هي بدت من قبل علاقه
شغلنا مع بعض لان هو كان مدير اعمالك ايضا
او ما زال عمالك
لكن هو
طلب يدي للزواج قبل قبل ما يكون بيناتنا
في المشروع بتاع عمل لكن هو الان مهند هو
الشريكي في في مشواري الفني وفي مشروع
الفني مشروع عصفوره السودان وزوجه في نفس
الوقت لكن اوضح للناس انه هي العلاقه اللي
بيني وبينه قصه الحب اللي بيني وبينه كانت
قبل قبل
الاداره عمالي الشغل اكثر والله والله هذه
العلاقه باكثر تطغى فيه ما بين انصاف ههه
في البدايه زي ما قلت لك ان هي كانت
العلاقه بعدها كانت توقنا العلاقه بيناتنا
في شغل بياناتنا في يعني افكار متبادله
وهو ذول فنان ودول باحث في التراث
وبيناتنا في افكار يعني حلوه يعني بيناتنا
مشاريع كبيره فالحمد لله هي توجد بالنجاح
في في كل في كل الاوقات انا سعيد جدا
وسعيده بتعاوني معه وسعيده
بحاجات الجميله اللي قدمناها بمشاريعنا
نجحت الحمد لله
بتمنى ان احنا نكون متواصلين ومتحابين الى
ان نوصل صوره دائما ان شاء الله دائما لكل
العالم طب يا انصاف يعني معنى ذلك بان
الحب هو الاساس ومن ثم جاء العمل خلينا
نحكي شوي عن العمل
هل هو شيء سهل يسهل العمل ولا ممكن يعقدوا
لما الواحد بكون عماله بيعمل مع شريك
حياته مش بس في البيت ولكن ايضا في مكان
العمل
بالعكس الحاجه دي مريحه جدا
وبيسهل ليه كمان العمل لانه احنا حتى في
عملنا بنعمل بحب يعني
مشاريعنا بنعملها بحب وبنكون يعني منتظرين
منها ثمره يعني
تنال استحسان الشعب السوداني واحنا كل
مشاريعنا
في في اسعاد الشعب السوداني
وبنقدم يعني احنا حاليا في ظل ظروف صعبه
اللي هي ظروف الحرب
الدعوه الاساسيه بتاعتنا هي السلام يعني
في الحرب والتامين
استقرار المواطن السوداني البسيط المكلوم
الذنوب والظروف الصعبه دي لكل الناس اللي
بيتابعوني وبيعرفوني وعارفين بهدف ليش
السلام والدعوه للمحبه والوحده والتنوع
وقبل الاخر فده مشروعنا وده دعوتنا وده
هدفنا وهمنا الاول للسودان العمومي عسى
الله يوفقكم شكرا جزيلا لانصاف فتحي يعني
كنت معنا وان شاء الله مهند ما يمارس
الدورين في ذات الوقت يفصل ما بين مدير
الاعمال وما بين الزوج
وعندنا اوكي طيب هذه اللي انا كان بودي
أساله هل اليوم مهند يمارس دور مدير
الاعمال ايضا في البيت ولا لا زوج زوج
ومدير الاعمال ومدير اعمال
هو زوجي في البيت ومدير اعمال في العمل
يعني يفصل فيما بينهم ولا يخلط هو طالما
مش موجود معانا خلينا خلينا نتكلم
ناخذ راحتنا له يفصل بيناتهم
شكرا جزيلا حتى في في
مساله الزواج اللي احنا احنا كنا موقفين
للزواج في نفس التوقيت فصادف الحرب فاحنا
كنا مصرين انه احنا
نكمل الزواج في في نفس التوقيت الرغم من
انه الظروف هي كانت مع مناسبه لكن خلاص
احنا بقينا الامر الواقع وانه هو توقيت
محدد
كل الاصدقاء وكل الاصحاب ايوه كل الاصحاب
اللي شاركوا الحمد لله
يعني الحمد لله انا مدير اعمالك ما اعترض
على زواجك
حدد موعد شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار نج
وى القطط والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات